prendersi un giorno io sono la vj ed
oggi siamo su un videogame
anzi su il video che siamo su ratchet
and clank ragazzi allora prima di
cominciare volevo farvi una premessa
questo videogame ratchet and clank
uscirà tra un mesetto su playstation 4
però la sony mi ha mandato in anteprima
il gioco così che io potessi giocarlo
per voi volevo ringraziare la sony per
aver permesso questa cosa non potevo
farmi vedere l'inizio del gioco perché
sennò mi mandava mi spediva ma da sca
man però innanzitutto ratchet e clank e
ha fatto parte della mia infanzia più
dei miei genitori un altro po per me
giocare a questa cosa in anteprima
equivale a volos o avere belen rodriguez
come fidanzata per i ragazzi lui e
ratchet quest'uomo peloso che che c'è
questa chiave inglese po grossa mentre
ragazzi il robottino che sta dietro con
attaccato alle spalle e clank questo
query venditore di armi è la cosa più
bella di questo gioco forse il
rivenditore di armi perché a un certo
punto del gioco ti vende delle armi che
non stanno nè in cielo nè in terra di
ocio 2000 bulloni me ne servono 4 mila
se poi bulloni sarebbe rivolto a quanti
di voi ragazzi magari già lo conoscono
ratchet e clank ora scusate se vi spiego
le cose proprio nel dettaglio perché
magari c'è qualcuno che non lo conosce
nel caso vi ho appena fatto scoprire la
vita grazie di sparargli in faccia siete
gentilissima ecco una cosa di ratchet e
clank fantastica è che non si sa da dove
non si sa perché non si sa quando ma la
gente ti spara in faccia e non te ne
accorgi dopo che tra sparato in faccia
te ne accorgi propri mano la mia mossa
preferita quando ci giocavo mi cagano la
mia mossa preferita quando ci giocavo da
piccola era lanciare la chiave inglese
poi sempre da piccolo mia madre mi
lanciava le ciabatte proprio è un altro
discorso
devo arrivare almeno 4.000 volte perché
si arriva a 4000 riesco a prendermi
l'arma nuova con la [ __ ] questo ha
negato pazienza si è fatta notare un
paio di cazzi tuoi mcauley perfetto è
rimasto così comunque lega mi son
dimenticato di dirvi che questo qua
quanta gente dio mio questo ratchet e
clank qui è un remake per alimentarlo
fatto un ritmo
dei vecchi ratchet and clank e gli hanno
messo insieme io non ci posso cosa stai
facendo è successo la vedessi ha già il
sindaco no perché alla ferme io a questo
gioco qua ci avevo giocato quando stava
ancora nella pancia di mia madre
so che devo salvare il sindaco dentro la
navicella giusto ok allora devo far
fuori tutti sti tizi finché non
legalizzi la fibra in tutto il paese un
cazzo che ti salvo io potreste levarvi
dai cabasisi mezzo secondo no perché dio
mio su cristiano che chiuso da un'ora e
mezza ok ha salvato guarda che che in
gioco che no con sti baffi scheme stava
casca della videocamera che bello mi
sono perso cosa è successo ma non
importa la ragazzi mi mancano 10 punti
in croce un altro po per prendere la
moda non ci credo 46 bolt per prendere
l'arma noah eccoli che culo che con
l'incredibile 84 e ne servono 4 mila
dying datemi la cassa in più a sinistra
su una casa ce l'avete trova qualcuno
che i quali la nave
certo perché io passo e cadono le cose
dal soffitto è una volta ho anche fatto
cadere il lampadario da piccolo procura
un'altra roba
devo uccidervi scusate se era un po le
tre guardie mi servono involti grazie
mille non tornare indietro un attimo
assolutamente devo prenderla una nuova
subito per rispetto posso prenderla
questa qui 4.000 punti non so che cosa
diavolo esce fuori non ne ho idea
proprio preso parola faccia fiera non so
bene che cosa mi serve a questa cosa
dove ma è una sfera del drago questo
devo lanciata in faccia e ma devo
provarla
sono morto oddio come mi sono salvato
dove son finito ragazzo un gradino mamma
mia che salvataggi incredibile noi siamo
e non ho visto perché mi ha buttato giù
lurido come hai fatto a salire la sopra
ma colpisce ripetuta stile simile e
colpisce i nemici viveva bene fortissimo
già vinto perché ho già vinto il gioco
per voi che però in realtà ragazzi la
mia arma preferita di ratchet and clank
e la torretta quella che quando la
piazza vis faceva tutto lei di morire
dice in faccia quando a porta
e poi tra l'altro ragazzi non ve l'ho
detto ma il suo gioco qua ogni tanto
bisogna avvitare dei bulloni che non è
che gli habitat e con la mano cioè ci
girate intorno perché sono talmente
grossi dovete girarci intorno è
bellissimo ma è bastato un bullone per
attivarlo la tecnologia questo
sterminato una famiglia con un colpo
fantastico
sono arrivato che belve il primo piano
sul culo che cosa interessante ha già
l'idraulico quello che vidi parola nave
questo giusto credo che questo tizio mi
riporti alla navicella in teoria sì
infatti nelle fogne fantastico bravo
complimenti uomo si è lanciato nelle
fogne
si si erano fogne e ratchet purtroppo ma
io sedevo lanciarmi anch'io nelle fogne
quella che sto vedendo li emerge è
quello che penso io lo faccio che vi
devo dire
a nostra volta ok amica pensavo fosse
un'altra roba
va bene così anzi mai quanti bulloni
dentro le fogne
cos'è la gente caga bulloni oppure
la spiega sta cosa la cosa che
l'idraulico iniziarono a ricordare
l'astronave non sapevo cosa stai
avvitando regge cosa stai abitano cosa
ma ora dovrebbe funzionare certo grazie
dell'aiuto nessun problema al prossimo
remake al prossimo remake bellissima
vabbè vabbè geniale ad ora i videogiochi
quando si pigliano per il culo da soli
c'è il tizio sapeva che questo è un
remake di ratchet e clank verso
l'infinito erano quella era un'altra
roba sapete che ciò l'alzheimer quindi
non mi ricordo bene le cose però mi pare
che dico ci fosse anche l'arena oggi
chance che il credito la vita propria
star liberiamo era dai perma ragazzi
prima che la videocamera mi faccia un
tonfo per terra richiamo solibello mio
dio no aver visto ricordato adesso mi
danno il potenziamento per clank mi
danno le dico perché in realtà il
robottino dietro finora non ha fatto una
mazza di niente ma non è inutile in
realtà gli spunta un elicottero dalla
testa che mi fa tipo planar ed è
fortissimo
in teoria adesso stiamo andando dal tipo
che mi mette a posto l'anno di cotte
credo e non ne sono sicurissimo ancora
tua zio di crepare però
e tra l'altro come è morto bellissimo
che posso
sono entrato va c'è il tizio c'è il
tizio che mi fai che li mette
l'elicottero certice mettere di quattro
fermi natio mi fai vedere il tizio che
figo che sembra mio compagno delle
superiori uguale soprattutto quanto e
peloso tanto ragazzi mi metti un
elicottero che non si sa non ho mai
capito come fa stare dentro il robottino
perché l'elicottero e grosso fatte non è
possibile in teoria con questo che
dovrei riuscire a planare credo mi fai
posso uscire grazie fratello ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio perché in realtà
non so se posso farvi vedere di più devo
chiedere perché dio mio paura sempre di
andare ad aqaba non pensavo mai di
rivedere il ratchet e clank con una
grafica così perché io me lo ricordo
come era per play due ragazzi che un
cross che l'episodio
veramente io sono troppo contento di
essere riuscito a giocare a ratchet e
clank per voi perché è uno dei giochi
della mia infanzia insieme a jack and
daxter centrata erano questi due quanta
patata c'avevo da piccolo non avete idea
per i ragazzi si farà una vita vi sia
piaciuto cosenza video piaciuta
sull'argomento è un mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook come nei video totale
iscrizione sensi di schede diavolo
cozzolino e ragazzi